it has been over 24 hours since that
fatal accident on d.i indicator that
killed a pedestrian today many are
questioning safety christian casara
spoke to some residents about more that
can be done to protect them
we have the problem with the people no
no use the line the people not use the
lying crushing between the street this
is the problem we met melva sanchez
today on her daily trip to the grocery
store she says it can be a scary walk
because not everyone is focused on what
they're doing the problem here because
the people is
watching the people when they cross the
street
today desert inn near decatur was back
to normal after thursday afternoon's
deadly accident according to police a
65-year-old woman jaywalked and was
killed by a school bus with three
elementary school students on board it's
a situation many can relate to have you
ever had any close calls yeah
in fact i was hit
traffic safety organizations like zero
fatalities are urging both drivers and
pedestrians to watch out for each other
they say 63 percent of pedestrian deaths
happen outside the crosswalks and in the
evenings as of october 27 of this year
metro police reporting 37 pedestrian
fatalities compared to 34 this time last
year they just crossed you know where at
the corners
stuff like that standing in the middle
of the street
it'd be a hell of a lot safer melva
hopes this recent tragedy can bring more
safety awareness to both drivers and
pedestrians christian casa is live local
now